le boeuf du québec profitent de
l'engouement pour l'achat local les
produits identifiés par la marque boeuf
québec qui étaient offerts exclusivement
sur les tablettes des magasins géants se
retrouve dorénavant dans d'autres
épicier mais l'industrie québécoise du
boeuf pourra-t-elle répondre à la
demande et se tailler une place parmi
les grands producteurs canadiens on va
parler d'ailleurs avec sylvain
charlebois qui directeur principal du
laboratoire en sciences analytiques en
agroalimentaire à l'université dalhousie
un grand grand titre monsieur charlebois
merci beaucoup de talent et je disais on
n'avait pas vu ça ça faut dire qu'avec
ton article après ce matin on n'avait
pas vu ça depuis 2007 une transformation
bovine aussi importante au québec on a
l'impression que les consommateurs ont
décidé de se tourner vers l'achat local
pendant la pandémie en fait des gros
salaires se tourne déjà vers l'achat
local qui s'occupe des coillard le
public avide yuma pour des produits
locaux le bluff ni à chapeau la sainte
et jpeg québec c'est toute sa vie qui se
développe depuis déjà quelques années
une approche cia qui est intéressant
c'est un projet qui a beaucoup de mérite
alors on prend en fait on prend
davantage ce qui se passe actuellement
pour annoncer une bonne nouvelle
c'était vraiment le problème au québec
la transformation la capacité de
transformation on commence à augmenter
la capacité de production transformation
québec meilleurs et quand même beaucoup
de thaï ha bah c'est un petit cheptel
combat d'image convoi d'alberto en
saskatchewan
oui absolument mais toujours un très
petit joueur si on se compare vous venez
de le dire à l'ouest canadien c'est là
que ça se passe encore une fois non on
laissait coup de dé tirer son épingle du
jeu à quelques ça ouais
ce qui m'inquiète avec le de façon
binaire assidi
je pense que là tu penses déjà qui nous
écoutons le salon est pas donnée voyez
26 pour s'annonce de bêtises pour cent
de plus jeunes les bêtes quand je mets
tout seul pendant qu'on sait c'est très
cher
alors pour se démarquer il faut que
boeuf québec donne
d'autres raisons que du fait que qu'elle
demeure vient du québec me [ __ ] qu'on
va devoir charge un petit peu plus mais
c'est un produit assez cher partons en
passe un oubli du boeuf à berthez par un
tank api temps pour du beurre peut-être
payé un petit peu plus pour un boeuf qui
dit chez nous donc et peut-être
davantage
qu'est ce qui explique alors venez de le
dire le prix est encore très très cher
mais qu'est ce qui explique ce
changement des habitudes de consommation
alors vous l'avez dit un peu donc on
veut favoriser le boeuf québécois
l'achat local est ce qu un meilleur
étiquetage est ce qu'une envie aussi
d'aider nos producteurs puissent y en
avait entendu eu toutes sortes de
problèmes d'éclosion de la corvette
d'endesa bras dans des abattoirs
ailleurs au canada
oui ça l'a pas aidé la finale romaine
canadiens en ont une fois nous ont
sauvés après détours de béganne 18 à
l'espace et à limiter son film troie le
mouvement la commune on continue donc de
plus en plus de gens qui boude la viande
poisson en europe incluant le peuvent
pour travailler sur l'image les tutrices
au québec royal c'est surtout la corrida
autre fait bien paraître la filière
bovine de façon générale donc en sortant
en quittant la bande à pandémie d'une
fois qu'on va terminer mais c'est
salomon faut redorer l'image mais encore
une fois je pour ce qui est de boeuf
québec
je pense qu'un potentiel intéressant
pour pour les québécois est aussi
populaire mais un auteur qu'on travaille
sur le marketing la commercialisation et
surtout au niveau des capacités amateurs
suisses qui manque depuis plusieurs
années ça ma prochaine question est ce
que les producteurs du québec ont la
capacité de servir les grandes chaînes
d'alimentation le youth parce qu'on est
capable de suffire à la demande
ce sont les avantages il ya quelques
vannes à qui elles se sont engagées
band of quebec des produits du québec
mais il faut devant le cse du bonhomme
et ses sapins que les bagarres on est à
la recherche de prix avantageux font
qu'un incitatif pour la chaîne de vendre
un produit de soin québécois ou re
produits qui arrivent d'ailleurs faut
passer tout seul donc pour ce cas
capacité d'accueillir vont devoir
augmenter si les projets pour en fait
faire en sorte que le produit de voir
intéressant surtout du fait qu'on va
être dans une récession pour un petit
bout de jungle on a discuté avec leur
budget alors faut s'assurer que le
produit demeure intéressant
financièrement
voilà vous voyez la capacité vous avez
parlé du prix mais aussi la question de
la qualité du boeuf qui produit 6 1
comment se compare avec ce qui est ce
qui est produit ailleurs très bonne
question en fait j'ai demandé au groupe
que la différence entre boeuf qui arrive
du québec meuf qui arrive d'ailleurs
et ça c'est une grande question il faut
il répondre parce que il faut justement
motivé la clientèle d'acheter un prof
québécois pour d'autres viennent du
québec
si on change plus cher il va falloir
justifier cette différence est
interminable attente rentré on n'a pas
d'ennemi accélérer la demande de
produits locaux en général on voit
d'ailleurs donc avec le boeuf ont leur
servent aussi d'aller dans les habitudes
plus générale les de consommation oh oui
absolument
c'est partout comme ça on le voit la
d'enlever un voisin qui vient lécher
aussi et c'est tant mieux moi j'ai passé
deux mois de mai où québec sera l'été et
j'ai remarqué vraiment qu'il va
délibérer et produits québécois à bon
prix aura plus là donc on voit qu'il ya
vraiment une mouvance qui sont des
moteurs ou la demande
c'est la voix merci beaucoup nous avons
été remis d'avoir pris clair également
merci beaucoup au revoir
quoi